et maintenant
jean-pierre castel
alors bonsoir bonsoir c'est la soirée
les mecs qu'on leur jeune parce que je
sais pas si on peut dire non quand 92 1
la semaine pourrait bien conserver aussi
jean pierre cazal incroyablement
conservez vous m'autorisez aldea oui
bien sûr 72 27 octobre bravo ça fait
rêver
alors est ce qu'on apprend dans l'ue une
grande fraction ne savaient pas s'ils
veulent vous l'annoncer crochon oui hein
alors sur vos trois enfants il y en a
deux qui ont gardé le pseudo de cassel
c'est vincent et cécile et y en a un
troisième qui s'appelle mathias mathias
crochon il en souffre pas ça va et tout
je crois par une version il y là il et
il fait du rap il a il a formé un groupe
s'appelle assassins et il se fait
connaître sous le nom de rockin squat
alors ce qui est drôle et ça aussi c'est
dans votre bouquin monica bellucci quand
elle est en famille ils l'appellent
monique crochon allez vous la trouvez
jolie monique très très belle très
extrêmement belle mais surtout c'est une
belle personne surtout elle a un peu
grossi récemment non mais ça y est plus
ouais c'est par s'est passé et son
accent ridicule vous trouvez pas ça et
j'accorde accent ridicule tout net où
elle un très joli accent italien
magnifique nous en vieux français dont
je l'adoré ils ont des accents qui font
bander sang italien en fait partie ouais
des accents étrangers qui font déborder
la claque son ensemble en voilà alors
vous êtes grand père donc d'une petite
deva qui né le 12 septembre à rome
alors c'est du sanskrit 1 je crois que
c'est une le nom d'une divinité indienne
effectifs ça veut dire beauté céleste en
sanskrit flâner bien nommé et vincent ça
va je crois qu'il va très bien alors il
ya un truc très gentil dans la préface
de votre livre il dit qu'il était un
jeune acteur en colère j'ai tout fait
dit il en parlant de vous pour me
démarquer de son image
et puis j'ai réalisé l'influencent qu'il
avait eue sur moi c'est c'est très
gentil quand même une très belle préface
il a écrit un très joli texte
qu'est ce qui n'a pas hérité de vous
vincent cassel
ma patience a un qui vit plus impatients
que moi il est moins bien les avec vous
je ne dirais pas ça je dis qu'il est
plus les plus sanguin mois alors que la
quête il il est moins bien que moi il
est bien meilleur sur beaucoup d'autres
choix qu'est ce qui vous énerve le plus
chez lui ce qui me fait beaucoup rire
mais ça c'est un peu dans de la famille
c'est sa mauvaise foi que je partage
avec lui c'était beaucoup rire en fait
beaucoup rire ça énerve pas mal les
femmes de la famille mais on en joue
beaucoup et ça nous amuse beaucoup en
fait il ya un truc que vous n'avez
jamais osé lui dire est que vous auriez
envie de lui dire ce soir par exemple
que tu n'es pas son vrai père de la
famille ils hésitent beaucoup à lui dire
ça il devrait dire à la première de
personnes profitent de la télé n'ont pas
pas vraiment joron sûr on se parle
beaucoup je rajouter tout dit ce qu'il
fallait dire au moment où israël quoi et
cécile cassel qu'on adore ici qui vient
s'en aille c'est que voulait ce que s'il
ya quelque chose que vous avez envie de
lui dire d'être patiente un d'être
patiente et de et de croire en sa bonne
étoile
voilà mes d2 c'est le cas le ton préféré
qu'est ce qu'elle est belle en tous les
cas
oui très belle et très farouche non
la fille
alors jean pierre cassel vous publiez à
mes amours chez stock ou vous raconter
votre vie à travers vos acteurs bon
réalisateur vos auteurs de chanteurs vos
amis vos femmes vos enfants enfin tous
ceux qui l'ont qu'ils ont marqué et on y
retrouve votre célèbre légèreté qui est
du dites-vous à un certain fatalisme
j'ai hérité de mon père sans doute
qu'ils étaient médecins généralistes un
certain fatalisme je crois je crois
qu'il n'arrive que s'il doit arriver et
je pense qu'on peut orienter quelquefois
certains événements qu'on peut qu'on
peut tordre le cou à certaines vérités à
certaines réalités mais qu'en fait la
vie que voilà et des c'est la vie qui
est écrite quoi vous dites il ya des
choses comme l'érosion des sentiments
auxquels on ne peut pas échapper mais le
reste on peut essayer de l'améliorer
voilà c'est très positif 1 oui j'ai sur
les i positif
ouais résite yvon vous allez jusqu'à
rendre hommage dans le bouquin à votre
première femme qui vous a quitté en
disant ben oui ça se passait mal elle et
elle est partie finalement c'est une
bonne chose alors sur le moment j'ai pas
citer aussi drôle que ça c'est pas drôle
ça c'est des choses qu'on réalise après
coup ici on est si on est honnête
effectivement sur le moment ces pages
pas du tout agréable et je les ai vécus
comme beaucoup de gens doivent le vivre
mais que c'est vrai qu'avec le recul si
votre vie se déroule mieux et où
débouche sur des horizons auxquelles
vous aviez pas pensé
on ne peut que remercier ce qui s'est
passé avant et pas mal du tout mais même
la maladie dont vous sortez vous arrivez
à y trouver du positif
oui je te dirais que j'arrive à y
trouver je suis bien obligé je pense que
les
je pense que les coups durs qui vous
arrive ça ne sert à rien de de lutter
contre et de dire ah oui mais en ce
moment je peux pas faire ça je loupé ça
et tout ça je crois que c'est pas du
tout le propos le propos c'est de
prendre les choses qui vous arrive et de
les essayer de les résoudre
comme s'ils étaient quelque chose un
compte qu'on a envie de faire voilà et
de la maladie pareil quoi ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'on gagne simplement que ça
aide c'est tout dans tous les cas je
dirais grâce à cette maladie
d'une certaine façon vous avez les
cheveux courts oui et j'ai écrit le
livre c'est vrai et j'ai sans doute
réviser pas mal de deux de mes
comportements et le jugement par rapport
à mon entourage et par rapport à aux
gens en général parce que on s'aperçoit
que comme on dit on remet les choses en
perspective
tout d'un coup on on s'attend à beaucoup
de choses on ont peu d'importance par
rapport à ce qui peut vous arriver ça va
là ça va bien ça va bien je suis vous
avez vous êtes émacié vous avez les
cheveux courts selon la jeune heather
oui vous ressemble à vincent cassel
de plus en plus je suis très fier de ça
ça me fait très plaisir
alors voulez-vous parler évidemment de
tous les gens qui nous ont marqués fred
astaire il ya une phrase vous dit que
c'est une image fondatrice pour vous en
habit en cravate blanche avec 1,8
reflets sur la tête c'est à dire à haute
forme les marches la nuit dans une ville
sur une musique de jerome kern ça pour
vous c'est une image brouillée c'est une
image qui m'a beaucoup marqué c'est
magnifique et vous raconter quand vous
rencontrez john kelly sur la piste du
club saint germain et alors là vous
l'invitez chez vous oui à votre
anniversaire
il dit oui oui il dit oui parce que
c'était un homme très simple et il est
venu chez moi parce que c'était un type
qui venait en france il était curieux de
rencontrer les gens il avait connu au
club saint germain et 10 bat wil à
l'anniversaire de jean pierre et là il
m'a montré un pas de claquettes que je
continue à faire
un américain à paris et puis les
réalisateurs lorsque très très bizarre
si vous n'ayez jamais tourné avec
jacques demy
oui vous auriez pu être vous dans l'est
dans les parapluies de cherbourg où les
demoiselles de rochefort
oui ça c'est pas trouvé assez voilà
jacques demy jamais que lucho tu aies
jamais non
alors que ça a été ça fait cher à claude
sautet l'a23 repris pas mal non plus en
plus en revanche alors broca évidemment
philippe de broca venu nous donner
énormément drôle vous étiez un peu son
acteur fétiche à un moment et ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'en fait il avait
plus de succès avec les films qu'il
faisait avec belmondo
c'est avec les films qu'il faisait avec
vous voyez comme ils se projeter en vous
il a pris ça comme un échec personnel
peut-être mais peut-être en tout cas
sûrement celle là ça l'à beaucoup
beaucoup meurtri et puis surtout on a on
a vieilli différemment philippe et moi
on à moi j'ai eu envie tu résides de de
changer de registre et de d'aller vers
des choses plus plus dense plus ambigu
faisais et je pense que philippe au
contraire a voulu s'accrocher à une
certaine incertaine humour une certaine
l'image de deux chenapans de personnel
associé à tout type qui en tant
qu'interprète ne me satisfait pas alors
il ya une scène terrible dans votre
bouquin c'est quand vous êtes tous les
deux chez castel et il prend un verre
comme ça un verre de vin rouge
il l'a dans la main il le sert comme ça
et le verre explose
oui et d'un seul coup vous dites vous
découvre un personnage que vous ne
soupçonniez pas du tout une très grande
force intérieure et une très grande
oui c'est quelqu'un c'est quelqu'un qui
est très très intenses et qui je crois
qu'il m'aimait beaucoup revanche j'aime
toujours beaucoup d'ailleurs c'est mais
que julie et des choses pas agréable et
au lieu de deux projetés ça sa colère 20
mois et ben il a pété le vert ouais
c'est bizarre parce que vous vous
séparez vous vous retrouver pour chouan
et vous dit on se quittera plus jamais
et puis après vous restez 23 ans en
faire quoi que ce soit ensemble c'est
oui c'est bizarre c'est bizarre c'est
les scénarii qui
qui ne correspondent pas ce qu'on attend
vous parlez de votre grand amour de
jeunesse françoise dorléac soeur de
catherine deneuve en quinze jours vous
apprenait qu'elle s'est tué sur la route
en allant à l'aéroport de nice
vous réagissez pas vous rester sec et
vous dites finalement ce bizarre je suis
pas je suis pas ému et vous vous
réalisez sa mort un jour en me garant
devant devant repeint c'était que votre
mère d'ailleurs oui plus tard et il voit
là il s'est assise à ce moment là que
j'ai réalisé ce qui est ce que ce à quoi
elle correspondrait le monde qu'elle
allait mais c'est alors voilà à vous
raconter votre vie avec cassel je
n'avais passer du temps chez castel voix
oui beaucoup beaucoup vous êtes un cas
stelliens de la grande peur était cassel
chez casterman c'est ça avec pierre
bénichou 1 c'était vraiment les acolytes
qui vous fait toutes vos fêtes là bas
les dix ans avec anne cassel c'est chez
castel à tous les grands événements sont
chez castel exit les rats et vous parlez
de cette dance canada qui s'appelle la
bostella
ryan se propage chanteuse rose comme à
vis d'apple mais peu voici le voilà
la nuit est
mais la vie des longtemps ou alors ça
c'est la bostella c'est à dire que ça
commence comme ça avec des gommes nexar
d'ascom ça pour l'allégresse et alors
les gens les gens se précipiter sur la
piste il sortait comme ça sur sur
eux-mêmes et taper des mains et puis au
moment où ça devient langoureux et où
tout le monde tombait par terre les uns
sur les autres
il y avait seize de magma l'humain où
vous vous êtes des gens se troubler par
dépit d'un coup ça reprenait tous ont su
relevé et ça a été pendant quelques mois
je crois chez castel une espèce de folie
après ouais une vraie folie
il ya eu des faits des poignets cacher
des des bulls et des montres volées des
mains baladeuses de réception
hallucinant comme c'est un mec qui
s'appelait honorer un type hyper drôle
très très intelligente journalistes de
grands grands talents et qui avait eu
cette idée là sur l'art comme ça alors
ce que j'ai appris en lisant votre
bouquin c'est que vous avez joué au
théâtre nu devant giscard d'estaing sur
la scène du palais royal de jean-michel
routière c'est une pièce vous étiez le
personnage arriver croyant avoir rendez
vous avec son masseur il rentrait nu sur
scène et ils tombaient sur anny duperey
qui était en fait j meneur du magic a
été un soir dans la salle effectivement
et ce qui m'a beaucoup amusé c'est
qu'effectivement le square où il était
là il s'est arrangé pour se tourner
discrètement vers ma femme qui était
dirais comme ça et ne pas regarder du
tout le plateau alors on va rester dans
le théâtre puisque vous êtes sur scène
en ce moment le talent ateliers dans une
pièce qui s'appelle est la folie pas du
tout des douars albicy café virginia
woolf
alors à partir d'une question à la fois
simple et compliqué tu m'aimes
voilà c'est un couple qui se rend compte
qu'il est sans succession de petites
petites scènes très brève et très
très très caustique et très fin très
plein de sens chaque fois et où on
découvre peu à peu la vérité de ce
couple qui est pas forcément très très
drôle mais c'est traité sur un mode
vaudevillesque puisque albi a mis en
sous titre de sa pièce et vaudeville en
français et la pièce fait beaucoup rire
et sans doute beaucoup réfléchi entre et
c'est très étonnant sur le plan de la
mise en scène c'est il y un café
ordinaire lui c'est qu'à un moment il ya
un panneau qui descend avec marquez
identifiez vous et donc les acteurs
s'identifie nice et ça et je m'appelle
jean pierre cassel présent et moi
j'étais très inquiet de cette histoire
parce que je trouvais ça après le très
dérangeant que j'ai comme en public va
réagir
il se trouve que c'est un des moments de
la pièce où les gens adorent absolument
s'est laissé aller fait beaucoup
beaucoup rire parce que ça les prend à
contre pied et que tout d'un coup voir
ces deux acteurs qui ont joué monsieur
et madame tout le monde enfin un couple
comme ça se présentait elle à l'arrivée
aux besoins de ma part je m'appelle
daniel le brun je suis comédienne été et
ça c'est l'effet hurler de rire il
valide et de mise en scène
oui
après
et tous les jeux
avec moi